en este vídeo
te voy a probar que el límite cuando x
tiende a cero de seno de x
/ x es igual a 1 pero antes de hacer
esto antes de que me meta a
trigonometría para probar este límite no
era un aspecto relacionado con límites
que es interesante este el teorema del
sándwich una vez que entiendes el teo en
el sándwich es fácil probar esto hay una
explicación muy simple para entender
esto y la vas a encontrar simple si es
que agarra la explicación si no siempre
es útil e importante memorizar este
límite sobre todo posteriormente que
veamos derivadas de funciones
trigonométricas entonces qué es el
teorema el sándwich y el teorema del
sándwich es uno de mis favoritos en
matemáticas porque tiene la palabra
sándwich en el teorema del sándwich y
cuando lo ves en un libro de cálculo yo
no sé si es el cálculo pre cálculo pero
bueno cuando tú lo ves en un libro de
cálculo parece muy complicado pero lo
que estipula es algo bastante obvia
déjame darte un ejemplo
si yo digo que yo sal
siempre
come
más
su mamá
su mamá es mi esposa si te digo que esto
es verdad sal siempre come más que un
mamá y si también te digo sal
siempre
come
menos
no se dejaba inventar un nombre
digamos vil
y esto es para cualquier día digamos
cualquier día sal siempre come menos
perdón sal siempre come más que mamá y
también cualquier día sal siempre come
menos que bill entonces si te digo que
el martes
obama
comió
300 calorías y el martes bill comió 300
calorías mi pregunta es cuántas calorías
sal comió comí el martes bueno siempre
como más que un mamá más o igual que un
mamá y siempre como menos o igual que
bill por lo que el martes debí haber
comido 300 calorías este es el meollo
del teorema del sándwich y luego
desarrollar formalmente un poco más pero
lo que dice esencialmente es que si
siempre soy mayor que algo y siempre soy
menor que otro algo y en algún punto
éstos coinciden entonces mi valor es
igual al que ellos tienen
estoy por así decirlo en el medio del
sándwich estoy entre un mamá y billy si
el martes ellos coinciden entonces mi
valor debe ser igual al de ellos o por
lo menos acercarse a él déjame
plantearlo en términos matemáticos
lo que se plantea en el teorema del
sándwich es que sobre algún dominio si
tenemos que
gx es menor o igual a fx y menor o igual
que hdx
esto sobre algún dominio y si también
sabemos que el límite
deje de x cuando extiende a es igual
algún valor digamos l y si también
sabemos que el límite
cuando x tiende a
de hdx también es igual a l entonces el
teorema del sándwich plantea y no lo va
a probar aquí pero es bueno saber qué es
lo que estipula el teorema del sándwich
el teorema de sandwich estipula que
entonces el límite
cuando x tiende a
de fx tiene que ser también igual a él y
aquí podemos ver el ejemplo que
planteamos donde esto es lo que come sal
al día
aquí tenemos lo que come o mama al día y
aquí tenemos lo que come bill yo siempre
como más que un mamá y menos que bill y
entonces el martes puede decir que ésta
es el martes su mamá comió 300 calorías
y bill también comió 300 calorías
entonces yo tuve que haber comido 300
calorías déjame hacer la gráfica
demostrártelo gráficamente guatema otro
color
teorema del sándwich teorema del
sandwich
graphic hemos el punto y coma el
entonces supongamos que aquí en el eje x
tenemos el punto a este es el punto a y
en el eje y el punto l entonces que de x
es nuestra función menor debe ponerle
aquí en verde aquí tenemos entonces que
de x que ésta tiene
aquí viene gx y sabemos que el límite
cuando x tiende a dg x es igual a l
aquí tenemos g de x entonces
entonces esto es de x
y déjame hacer ahora hdx con un color
distinto ahora hdx se puede ver algo así
algo como esto
algo así esto es hdx y sabemos de hdx
también que el límite cuando x tiende a
dh x es igual a l
aquí tenemos el eje el eje que
corresponde en este caso a hdx y también
a gdx afp x es el eje la variable
dependiente y este acá es el eje x
nuevamente el límite cuando x se
aproxima a de hd x es igual a l hdx es
igual a l o al menos se aproxima a l
ahora suponiendo que bueno estas
funciones no necesariamente tiene que
estar definidas en a mientras estos
límites existan mientras este límite
exista y este límite también exista para
que nos dice esta expresión nos dice que
ft x siempre está arriba deje de x
arriba esta función verde y es menor que
hdx f x tiene que verse en este rango
está acotada por esas dos funciones
y va a tener que pasar por ahí va a
tener que pasar por este punto o al
menos se va a aproximar ese punto aunque
no esté definida pero el límite cuando x
tiende a df de x tiene que ser igual a
ese punto a el f x no tiene que estar
definida y pro límite cuando se aproxima
vamos a de fx tiene que ser también el
punto l espero que esto te ha hecho
sentido y que mi ejemplo las calorías
también te haya hecho sentido
mantengamos en nuestra memoria entonces
el teorema del sándwich y ahora vamos a
utilizar eso para probar qué
el límite
el límite cuando x tiende a 0 de seno de
x sobre x es igual a 1 y quiero hacer
esto porque es un límite super útil pero
también porque cuando aprendes el primer
sándwich dices bueno es obvio pero para
qué me sirve esto y veremos de hecho lo
hace el siguiente vídeo porque ya
estamos cerca de los 8 minutos pero lo
que veremos en el siguiente vídeo es que
el teorema del sándwich es tremendamente
útil para probar esto lo veremos en el
siguiente vídeo